[Music]
over watching the game with plenty of
highlight-reel moments but none are more
satisfying to watch than a six-night now
the usual host call McNeil was wounded
in a tragic sniping accident and so I'll
be replacing him daniel rossen but you
know what's not tragic the overwatch
leagues first season which was filled
with plenty of sweet sniper plays from
wicked widow-makers to macri's
decimating people in midair here are the
top 10 Snipes of the overwatch league's
inaugural season kicking off our list at
number 10 is an impressive falling snipe
from the LA valiance KSM using the infra
set from bunnies Widowmaker and showing
off some otherworldly 8 KS F Han Zoe's
dropped architects Widowmaker with a
perfectly placed headshot that'll be
curry who takes out the sleepy from
range for the headshot KS temple
actually later architect as he comes on
the planks coming in at number 9 is one
of the deadliest players in the o WL
that's right it's New York Excelsior
spine whose McCree takes up Boston's par
a mid-air before putting on a show that
ends with him taking out a strikers
tracer in a fashions that we've come to
expect from the Big Bopper we're gonna
see how long he wants to live in his
life because he's going to have to try
to deal with mine you can do it
Wow not that time he can't as he gets
disconnected from his mercy finds
himself in kind crosshairs right there
and continued to get he's so agro on
this McCree he rolls in somersaults and
that's another three kill life for pike
so in the span of 25 second sentence
before he kills someone else this is
unreal in an incredibly close stage one
game against the LA gladiators fleet
--is Widowmaker not only helped secure
his team to win but also the number 8
spot on our list
grappling up the side of junker Town
Flay defines an angle on Chaz and lets
his reflexes do the rest
anything going 10 seconds left speed is
not suitable defense three from three
slept the goal it down with the LA
support down so were able to secure the
map one victory and the gladiators
played right into their hands it's one
thing to hit Snipes with Barras rockets
put her concussive blast well our number
seven plays showcases just that as the
Houston outlaws [ __ ] finds not one but
two long range kills by knocking know me
and AK right off the map they couldn't
get enough pressure onto Jake who
playing very individually and the IRISA
hog and then when they go onto this
stage it kind of flips around that's
certainly one way to put your team on
the board early making his second
appearance on this list at number six is
Big Boss Pie who slipped behind enemy
lines to pull off a series of
spectacular plays that culminate with
one of the filthiest flicks we have ever
seen
just absolutely nails in here even some
ashika what up plus all this guy is a
living highlight real bad putting up a
strong push on offense Swedish DPS
legend to Veeck rounds out the top five
of our list after helped him take down
the LA valiance man pointed to polo unko
and agility straight out of the sky
breathing is key the chance for a second
check the ball to Vic he has killed
Agility's three times in that fight both
resurrects were used on Agility's
intimidates him or de mayhem player sia
player comes in at the number four spot
on our list after winning a crucial
Widowmaker duel and following up on two
eqo sia player made an aggressive
graphic to catch the retreating player
and now he's looking to cut him off as
they retreat sure enough there it is
boom box is dead Ziya player so good the
deaths mentioned in the premium and I
think everyone knows this about the
Florida team that if they're going to be
going to victory it's going to rely on
science very capable shoulders to bring
them this straight from the overwatch
league's inaugural season finals our
number three play features the London
Spitfire facing down a charging
Philadelphia fusion that was until
profit hit a timely dragon strike
through the wall
catching almost the entire team enroute
to a championship this is
[Applause]
[Music]
dominant Korean marksman Flay defines
himself at the runner-up spot on our
list after dusting sure fors Widowmaker
mercy attempted to fly in for a
resurrect unfortunately for the
gladiators flee to hit this disgusting
airborne shot on big goose that just
shouldn't be allowed to happen
back up again flit up there's nothing
you can do about the place number one
snipe comes from the Philadelphia
fusions carpet who showcases his
lightning quick reflexes as he finds a
creative angle to dismantle the San
Francisco shop flying over the parapets
of eicken wolde carpe blasted dak right
out of the air before absolutely
deleting the enemy Widowmaker
carpe gets the counter Saipan the Navy
bait that frees my bow that Dad goes
down carpe totally going wild on this
Widowmaker right now oh and that's our
list of the best sniper place in the
overall eaves first season if you think
we missed any make sure to hit the
comments below and be sure to snipe that
subscribe button we've got a mercy
heading for Colin McNeill so he'll be
back with you next week thanks for
watching if you want more great content
just like this be sure to hit the
subscribe button
[Music]